Oh
yeah.
I mean I read a whole book on
checklists.
He'd be,
why in the world would anybody write a
whole book on checklists?
And,
and it was the last thing I thought I
would be writing about,
but I've been fascinated by how we
grapple with risk and complexity in
medicine.
And I got assigned a project to try to
find a way to reduce deaths in surgery.
We,
um,
had been struggling with our
performance.
And so I started looking at how people
in other fields grapple with the
enormously increasing complexity that
people in professional worlds are
dealing with.
And what I found was in the aviation and
skyscraper building and other lines of
work,
that there was something really
fundamental going on.
We had transformed from a world where
ignorance was our biggest struggle as
human beings.
This is the way it was for millennia.
We didn't understand why the human body
fails,
how to,
how to build things really well,
how to do many,
many kinds of tasks in the right way
that knowledge was missing today.
However,
our biggest struggle is with what people
call an aptitude.
Meaning the knowledge is there,
but somebody is not doing it right.
Um,
and in surgery,
in other parts of medicine,
what we're finding is that the amount of
knowledge,
the volume,
the complexity,
the tons of papers coming across the
transom,
the technologies that are proliferating,
that all of it has exceeded our
abilities as individuals to hold it all
in our head and do it right.
And there are lots of fields,
it turns out where this has been
happening.
Um,
constructing buildings well,
uh,
in making good investment decisions by
hedge funds.
Um,
and when I looked to see how people who
actually are solving these problems,
we're solving it,
I thought you'd find that they had just
trained in a different way or they had,
they had,
they were training longer and harder.
They had a different kind of use of
technology.
Instead,
what I found over and over again was
they use checklists as simple and
mundane as it sounds that the checklist
in a way filled in for weaknesses in
people's brains,
things that they forgot.
Um,
it also filled in for weaknesses and
making teams work.
Teams constantly drop stuff between the
cracks.
And so we made a checklist based on what
I learned.
Actually I got folks from Boeing to help
us out.
How do you make a checklist?
I didn't think that that would be all
that hard.
It turned out to be hard and I'm,
one of the things they showed us was how
to,
how to really focus on making it swift
and usable.
We made a two minute surgery checklist,
had just 19 items.
Some of them were just make sure you
don't forget dumb stuff.
Make sure you gave antibiotics,
make sure you um,
have blood ready for a high blood loss
case.
And then there were other interesting
parts.
Um,
make sure everybody in the room has been
introduced by name and role.
Make sure the surgeon actually explained
to the team what their goals for the
operation are.
Make sure the anesthesiologist and nurse
had a chance to explain their plans for
the operation.
Um,
I put,
uh,
we put that checklist in eight hospitals
around the world ranging from rural
Tanzania to Toronto and Seattle and
every single hospital,
we put it in and had a double digit
reduction in complications.
The average reduction in death was 46%.
Um,
that made me realize there was something
much deeper and more important going on
here about this set of problems were
grappling with.
And in the modern world,
well on the one hand you'd say 0%.
Um,
when you look at,
we have about 13,000 diagnoses.
We've recognized the human body to have
four.
We have 6,000 drugs,
4,000 different kinds of medical and
surgical procedures and the,
um,
and we know for each of them there's
anywhere from half a dozen to many dozen
steps that we should make sure are done
correctly.
Um,
and we just rely on human memory.
The person in the office that you go to
to just remember what that stuff is and
we drop stuff all the time.
A friend of mine went in for a
depression.
Uh,
she,
she was just becoming really low.
Uh,
the doctor put her on an antidepressant
and for next three years they're
changing antidepressants,
trying to get it right.
And it was only much later,
it's three years that they realize,
oh,
we didn't check your thyroid hormone
level.
And she just had low thyroid hormone
levels,
two weeks of thyroid hormone,
and she was better.
She lost three years because of that.
So the surgery checklist is in place in
about 20% of American hospitals.
Some countries have implemented it
nationwide,
France,
the United Kingdom.
Um,
places like Ecuador are adopting it
nationwide.
But,
um,
uh,
but are people really using it in their
heart of hearts?
Are they in there?
Well,
in the surgery world we are adopting it.
Um,
but have we recognize the lesson that
maybe this is the way we ought to think
about that we ought to have literally
pick up a checklist when you come in
with a new problem,
um,
that we're not there with.
Every time we get on an airplane,
someone picks up a checklist.
Well,
there are,
um,
there's a cultural obstacle.
We see checklists as a weakness,
as individual practitioners.
Um,
you know,
if you were in seeing a surgeon and they
said,
hmm,
I better check a textbook on this or I
want to check my checklist,
uh,
we,
we're not there yet.
Culturally we're starting to be,
the second obstacle is,
um,
any old checklist is not the story here.
I mean we could end up just creating a
bunch of paperwork and tick boxes that,
that just get ignored and aren't really
valuable.
So the institutional obstacle is we have
to recognize this as a science in the
aviation world.
We have a national transportation safety
board that goes in and investigates
accidents and shows the lessons that a
Boeing or an Airbus then can adopt into
checklists and making the lessons
usable.
We need the same thing or kind of
Medical Safety Board and National
Institute for Health Systems Innovation
is what I would call it,
that would recognize for being
discharged to go home from a hospital.
There are six key components to a
checklist that every hospital should
have that we know make a difference in
reducing the likelihood that you're
going to bounce back into the hospital.
We print two inch that guidelines saying
what you should do for cardiac care,
but we haven't boiled it down to,
here are the six things.
One should never forget when you're in
there with that patient complaining of
chest pain.
Okay.